[Music]
last weekend I was riding in an uber
express pool my fellow female passenger
was angry she was dropped so far from
her destination so she tried to punch
the driver and steal his phone the
driver got out of the car pushing her
away defending himself
cops sped up pulling the two apart
assuming it was the driver's fault as he
was being interrogated by the police he
kept begging for his phone I need to
turn off my uber app he pled if I don't
pick up my next client they will charge
me for the trip and deactivate me from
the platform this 60-something Korean
man was more afraid of the wrath of uber
than the wrath of the police and rightly
so
uber could have unilaterally cut off his
livelihood with no hearing no notice and
no appeal this driver is an independent
contractor which in theory means he
should have complete independence over
setting his own rates working conditions
and contract terms however gate
platforms like uber use changing
incentives and the threat of
deactivation to exert unprecedented
control over their allegedly independent
workforce these statements may lead you
to believe that I'm anti business but
actually I worked it over when I joined
the company running their East African
operations
I was excited about creating thousands
of economic opportunities for people in
Kenya Tanzania and Uganda where
unemployment rates are really high and I
was excited about improving mobility and
today's hungry for convenient affordable
transportation but that excitement
quickly gave way to disillusionment
every two weeks I hosted focus groups
with around 20 drivers they told me
Alisa we're making no money on this
platform we work for a hundred hours
every week and they only take home $20
when I ran the historical data their
stories checked out
when uber first launched in the East
Africa they offered very generous rates
and bonuses to make the economic
opportunity and no-brainer drivers with
the encouragement of uber took out
multi-year loans to finance the
relatively new vehicles required to join
the platform one year after launch and
two weeks after I joined the company we
slashed rates by 35% shifting all of
that onto drivers it would not be the
last bait-and-switch the company would
pull when I raised concerns about driver
earnings to management their message to
me was clear gig workers are an
expendable resource for growth because
of the company's labor practices I quit
after a short six months - ironically
become an independent worker myself as
an independent worker I faced many
challenges like client's ghosting when
it came time to make their final payment
and going 18 months without health
insurance in Kenya 80% of adults are
self-employed this means that you have
no guaranteed salary no retirement
contributions no paid leave no employer
sponsored benefits and you have to pay
all your own expenses the issue of the
lack of protections for contract workers
may seem like a distant emerging-market
problem but the US economy is evolving
to look like Kenya's since 2010 the IRS
has reported a six percent year-on-year
increase in the number of independent
relative to full-time workers by 2020
half of Americans will be self employed
full-time w-2 workers in this country
have several protections thanks to the
labor movement which started around the
time of the Industrial Revolution
factory owners treated their workers as
expendable forcing them to work a
hundred hour weeks just to maximize
profits workers organized into unions
and rioted resulting in the 1938 Fair
Labor Standards Act which instituted the
40-hour work week ban child labor and
set standards around minimum wage and
overtime
pay none of these protections apply to
contractors which threatens to increase
the unprecedented levels of inequality
we see in this country corporations are
systemically contorting full-time
positions into contract positions to
minimize their fixed labor costs
oftentimes contractors will work for the
same single company for years by
changing nothing more than that
individuals formal employment status
companies are sidestepping the hard one
worker protections of the 20th century
and shifting risk from investors to
workers why do I care so much about this
Mis classification issue well my dad was
classified as an independent contractor
for the 25 years he worked at his
company he made less than $20,000 and
received no benefits if my mom a public
schoolteacher did not have generous
benefits I have no idea how he would
have retired or my family would have
access quality health insurance
some of the worst offenders of contract
worker abuse are in our own backyard
I learned five minutes before this
session started that Stanford is
increasingly shifting to contractors
rather than full-time employees to
reduce their benefits obligations such
as giving their employees free college
tuition for their children the
communications coaches who helped us
with these presentations are in short
term rather than full-time contracts
Google has more contractors on its
payroll than full-time employees how
many of you have ordered something on
Amazon Prime in the past month all of us
say Wow chances are that that package
was delivered to you by an Amazon flex
contract employee who post expenses can
make as little as five dollars an hour
under half of California's eleven dollar
minimum wage
contract workers in Arizona moderate
explicit content on the Facebook
platform they spend hours every day
watching horrific videos of murder and
sexual exploitation several suffer from
PTSD which Facebook of course provides
no support for because they're just
contractors not employees these
contractors make $15 an hour or a mere
$28,000 a year Silicon Valley fed by
Stanford talent has profited from
driving down the wages of low-skilled
workers we moved backwards as a society
back to where we were at the start of
the industrial revolution back to the
age of the hundred hour workweek and no
effective minimum wage back to the age
where workers rights are dependent on
the benevolence of management dependent
on the whims of the people in this room
rather than protected by law the good
news is that gig workers are organizing
to demand their rights in the past few
weeks
instacart shoppers took to Reddit and
Facebook forums to oppose instacart s--
policy of deducting tips from their
minimum guaranteed base pay this time
the workers won instacart
agreed to change its policy and pay out
tips separately from base pay and they
instituted new minimum payments per
delivery David won against Goliath I'd
like to leave you with this by being at
the GSB we are in a place of incredible
privilege our starting salary coming out
of this school will be a hundred and ten
thousand dollars higher than or two
point eight X the median household
income in the United States your
employer will almost certainly give you
health insurance and paid leave and
retirement contribution on top of
dinners at Nobu free trips to Cancun and
souls like al qasas I say that's not to
kill to you but to implore you to be a
voice for those who do not have
the same level of privilege you may be
wondering what you can do well you can
start by tipping tip generously and tip
with cash or another form of payment
where you know the funds will directly
reach workers beyond tipping you can
email HR if you witness contract worker
mistreatment within your organization if
you work in big tech chances are that
mistreatment exists if you see contract
workers working crazy hours or earning
wages that post expenses are below
minimum wage or see workers doing the
work of a full-time employee so they
deserve full benefits and if your
management is unwilling to listen like
mine was you can have the courage to go
to the press even anonymously
publications like the New York Times
recode and Bloomberg have exposed
stories that have shamed companies like
Facebook and instant ooh making changes
the disappearance of quality employment
opportunities threatens to exacerbate
the unprecedented levels of inequality
that we see in our country and our Bay
Area community searching your ethical
responsibilities to work workers may
seem like smart business but it stuns
the economic mobility of your workers
and their children don't be a part of
the problem be a part of the solution
towards just employment thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you